Sanji has the best character arc in One Piece
and I will proof to you why.
So I've kinda reached the point, where I feel
like Sanji is THE most controversially discussed
character in all of One Piece - which, let's
be honest, really says something. I mean basically,
every Twitter or reddit post and every YouTube
comment section basically look like this.
[insert meme] Except for you. Love you guys.
Anyways, even amongst the dumpster fire that
is large parts of the community, the Sanji
debate is burning as bright as his passion,
which I guess is part of the issue. And as
someone who's favorite character in the story
is Zoro, it would be very easy for me to add
some more fire to the flame. [stop he's already
dead]. However, if I did that, I honestly
would be lying, because to me Sanji is the
most well-written character in all of one
piece.
Hi my name is Manu and even though I don't
smoke - cigarettes - in this video, I will
not only proof to you that Sanji will leave
Wano as a changed man, but also clear his
and in extension Oda's name, of being a bad
writer when it comes to the man with the curly
hair - his eyebrows.
My original relationship with Sanji is probably
similar to yours: Pre-time skip Sanji was
an absolutely fantastic character. He was
not only a true gentleman, but arguably the
most mature member of the crew, scolding Luffy
for inappropriate behavior, protecting the
weaker members of the crew and even his chivalry
had more of an old-school James-Bond-sort-of
vibe. [Mr. Prince] During that time, deciding
who was my favorite between him Luffy and
Zoro was practically impossible, and also
unnecessary. There was a great balance between
the three, who had very different views, yes,
but nonetheless respected each other, protected
the crew and genuinely deserve the title of
the monster trio.
I guess some people might already have been
uncomfortable with Sanji's outdated views
on women, but it was clearly nothing compared
to after the time skip. I'm not gonna sugarcoat
it, Sanji has been extremely useless and even
worse than that: annoying, ever since the
straw hats left for fishman island. Through
Punk Hazard, Dressrosa and Zou, while Zoro
and Luffy were getting stronger and stronger,
reaching their full potential, Sanji often
failed to win an important fight and in many
situations, was just cringy to watch for his
nosebleed horniness.
And at that point, I fully agreed with the
people who thought that Oda had ruined Sanji's
great potential, by making him an annoying
and useless joke character. With Whole Cake
Island however, I was completely shocked,
but mostly relived to find out that this pitiful
version of Sanji I had seen since Fishman
Island, had actually been part of one the
best character arcs, I have ever come across.
And
the recent developments in Wano have now completely
evaporated my remaining doubts, so I can say
with full confidence that Sanji has not been
ruined. Just the opposite: I believe Oda's
portrayal of our cook, including his over-the-top
perviness, has been very much on purpose and
will make his growth just the more impactful
once it's complete.
One of the fundamental tools for great story
telling and creating a strong main character,
is the so-called hero's journey that you can
see here on the top RECHTS. And since all
the straw hats are designed as main characters
of their own, this can be applied to each
and everyone of them, which actually would
probably be very interesting to do. Maybe
I should make a series about that.
The first step in the heroes journey is the
call to adventure. And Sanji's adventure starts
in the most heartbreaking way possible: He
has to run away from his unloving family that
has physically and mentally abused him ever
since his mother died, ultimately locking
him in a cage with an iron mask. Getting this
piece of backstory was the first real mind-f''k
moment I had during Whole Cake Island, that
gave so much more context to his character.
The second step is meeting a mentor. For Sanji,
this person is of course Zeff. And again,
he has another traumatizing experience, almost
starving to death on an island. However, other
than his family, Zeff actually shows love
for Sanji and is prepared to die for him.
It's the first person since his mother that
treats Sanji like a human being and becomes
his new family, teaching him about cooking
and what it means to be a decent person. Most
importantly however, he gives Sanji his big
dream, which is to subscribe to Ohara's channel
to get his weekly fix of deep one piece analysis.
That and also to find the all blue.
This is where Luffy comes into play. He recruits
Sanji into his crew and gives him a chance
to fulfill his dream. He has now crossed the
threshold and has entered the world of pirates.
And for a while he overcomes his trials pretty
easily. With Mr. Prince, Enies Lobby and his
willingness to take Luffy's pain on Thriller
Bark, Sanji's popularity was at an all time
high. And then the first big failure. Sabaody.
However here it is the crew as a collective
or arguably Luffy as the captain, that fails
here.
And so along everyone else, Sanji grows from
this experience and develops new skills over
the time skip, which is exactly where Sanji's
downfall in popularity starts. How could that
happen? But will you look at that, it coincides
perfectly with the lowest point of the heroes
journey: Death and rebirth.
As I summarized earlier, Sanji comes out of
the time skip massively flawed: While his
ratio of coolness to pervert was maybe something
like 80:20 before the time skip, to me it
had now shifted to something close to 90:10
on the Pervy end. And I gotta be honest, of
course that would overwrite all the good associations
we have made with him before. And even more
frustrating, he was basically of no use to
the crew anymore. This negative spiral keeps
speeding up until finally, we hit rock! bottom!
with Whole Cake Island, where Sanji not only
leaves the crew, but even disrespects and
hurts his captain. He is reunited with his
abusive family who used him as a pawn for
a political marriage and in the end he even
has to learn that his to-be bride Pudding,
the only ray of hope in all of this, actually
had actually been plotting to murder him and
everyone else at the ceremony. [Sanji in the
rain]
You can see how that's Sanji's lowest point
in the story so far, right? Many people took
this scene as Sanji being heart-broken about
Pudding not loving him, but it's actually
the culmination of his entire character arc
so far literally pouring down on Sanji. And
the scene reflects that perfectly. Dark alone,
and crying. And this is where everything changes.
But to really appreciate Sanji's radical development
from here, you have to understand the main
point of Sanji's second backstory with the
Vinsmokes, that some people found irrelevant.
Because Sanji didn't go from awesome to the
state he's in here at Whole Cake island. You
need to understand, that this is how Sanji
has always seen himself. Right from the very
start, Sanji has had close to no self-worth
as a person. Which really is no big surprise
given his upbringing. I mean if you got told
you were worthless and treated like an animal
for the first 8 years of your life by your
Nazi family, how would you feel?
Wait what's that on the lens. Oh it's a sponsor,
that's convenient, cause my last video was
expensive. This video is sponsored by Skillshare,
the Sanji of sponsors. Skillshare is an online
learning community that offers thousands of
classes for all skill levels in tons of creative
and practical disciplines like filmmaking,
cooking and art. But it can really be anything.
Recently I've been trying to get back into
cooking and took this awesome class by Elena
Carp for the second time actually, on how
to properly use kitchen knife. Or how about
this course on how to make sushi? The first
1000 of you foxes to click the link in the
description will get a 1 month free trial
of Skillshare so you can start exploring your
creativity today.
So the baseline is: Sanji is the most self-sacrificial
straw hat, which is really impressive given
how often one of the straw hats pulls one
of these moments. But while Luffy risks his
life for his dream and Zoro risks his for
his principles, Sanji risks his life because
he feels indebted to people. This behavior
is established right from the start, during
the Baratie arc, where he refuses to leave
the restaurant because of his debt to Zeff,
despite literally being fired. And just a
bit later he is prepared to let Pearl kill
him for the exact same reason. When he offers
himself to the women he chases, he means it
quite literally. And the same of course goes
for the straw hats. He would rather be alone
and die rather than see his family hurt.
Sanji was born with incredible kindness and
altruism. His role on the ship is literally
taking care of the crew and making sure everyone
is healthy and happy. And he always fights
for the weak.
And it's also the reason why Sanji keeps going
on his solo missions. He wants to be of use
to the crew and take care of things on his
own. Which is one of the reasons why he gets
into fights with Zoro, who fights for everyone
in battle, but otherwise spends his time on
the ship sleeping and training. So: Yes. kindness
is inarguably Sanji's most! important! trait!
However combined with his abusive and traumatic
childhood, he is not able to extend that love
and care to the person that needs it the most:
himself. Someone compared that to this scene
from fire force, that I found incredibly fitting.
And at the same time, I also believe that
Sanji's perviness and sexism, come from the
same good place as well. The only two people
who showed him love as a kid were his sister
and his mother, who were both dominated by
his father and brothers. No wonder he would
put a woman on a pedestal and see them as
something beautiful that needs protection
from men. The second half of his life he then
grew up in a family of only dudes, all of
them tough-guy sailors. Of course he would
get that extra portion of macho with that.
Sanji grew up on sea his entire life. He is
the most piratey crew member. Well except
Jinbe, he literally lives in the ocean. [Spongebob
intro] And don't forget that Sanji spent 2
years on Okama island, chased around 24/7.
That's literally the reason why Oda made him
go overboard with all the intolerable nosebleed
stuff after the time skip.
And so going back to this rainy night on Whole
Cake island, Sanji's insecurity and lack of
self-worth have pulled him to rock bottom.
His perviness is not charming anymore, but
annoying, his solo missions aren't successful
anymore, but a burden, he has disrespected
his crew and captain only to find out it was
all for nothing, and as the crowning pile
of s''t on top he is back with the ungrateful,
emotionless family that caused this entire
mess.
And looking at our chart, it is here that
Sanji finally has his first big revelation.
He understands that going off on his own was
a mistake. That there are women who would
exploit his chivalry. That he disrespected
Luffy. And that his desire to save people
on his own is a burden on those he cares for.
But maybe the most heartbreaking thing is
that he finally understands that Luffy and
the others came to save HIM. That he was not
dispensable. That they cared so much for him,
that they would declare war on a Yonko. Sanji
cares so somuch about the people he’s
close to, both the strawhats and zeff, but
it doesn’t seem to occur to him that they
care about him just as much. What really broke
my heart is that he’s genuinely surprised
when luffy bombs into whole cake island to
rescue him even though literally anyone could
have predicted that in a heartbeat. I mean
Sanjihas witnessedluffy go through hell
and back for nami, robin, vivi, and ace, for
ace actually multiple times I guess, and still
doesn’t expect that he's worth that same
level of concern. Until that moment. Where
he sees Luffy, starving and beaten waiting
at the very spot he promised he would wait.
Whole Cake Island was Sanji's arc, because
he finally realizes his flaws. Just as Luffy
did with Robin, Nami and Usopp, he makes Sanji
shout out his true feelings to him and liberates
him from his emotional prison.[]
Luffy and the others love him for who he is,
and so Sanji saves the day in Whole Cake Island
by being the kind person he is, winning over
Pudding's heart, saving his family and even
baking the cake to stop big moms rage and
save all of his enemies. [Sanji's mother:
the kindest person]
And this phase of growth has carried over
to Wano. Spoiler Alert from here on out. One
of my favorite moments during the raid so
far has been Sanji calling Robin for help
when captured by Black Maria. trusting Robin
to fight Black Maria means, he now thinks
of Robin as a strong and reliable person instead
of a damsel in distress that needs to be saved
and kept out of danger. he swallowed his pride
and asked a woman to save him, even though
he always has been the one saving women through
the series. And I realized that this scene
stands in direct contrast to his stand-off
with Kalifa on enies lobby, where he refused
to trust in Nami. I mean just look how grateful
Robin is for this gesture. She's beaming.
And Marco gets it too.
So, now Sanji is getting his long-awaited
fight with Queen. However, the issue of self-worth
still remains. While he has overcome the trauma
of his upbringing in Whole cake island, he
still detests his family and now that his
own vin smoke abilities have awakened, he
feels disgusted and scared to lose his emotions.
Even though LuffY told him to his face that
he needs the kind Sanji, he now is wondering
whether Luffy might not prefer a heatless
machine to fight for him.
And so what Sanji now needs to realize, is
that his powers are already the opposite of
Germa. Queen said Judge wanted his kids to
have hearts of ice, but who stopped his plans?
Sanji's mother Sora, who sacrificed herself
and gave Sanji a burning heart of kindness,
the opposite to Judge's plans.
With this panel during the wedding, many readers
only see Sanji saving his family, but i see
SANJI AND his mother SAVING THEM, with Sanji's
burning heart.
A really nice nod to this is actually Sanji's
lighter, that looks suspiciously like his
mother giving him fire. By the way, there
is actually a real world version of this lighter
that was made as a special collaboration where
only about a thousand of these were made.
And I really need to get my hands on one of
these.
The next really huge step people overlooked
in this recent chapter, is that Sanji chose
to destroy his raid suit, that was a power
people disliked to begin with. As it turns
out, Oda only meant it to be a catalyst for
Sanji's true power-up. However much more important
than this, with this Sanji also starts to
overcome his arguably worst trait, his perviness.
Destroying the one thing, his perverted mind
always craved for.
In the end, Sanji will realize that he is
actually most successful with women, when
he is his true kind and caring self. No matter
if it's viola or Pudding, Sanji is staring
to understand that true chivalry is much closer
to the cool and caring spy-hero side of Sanji,
that we all fell in love with to begin with.
And in a more metaphoric sense, by destroying
the raid suit he literally choses not to hide
anymore, but be the crew mate luffy needs
by embracing who he is at heart. Which is
exactly what is gonna happen by the time Wano
is over.
But, and I think this is very important, he
still has to atone for what he did on Whole
Cake Island, especially in front of Zoro.
And speaking of Zoro, if you want a deeper
understanding of his character, I strongly
encourage you to watch my analysis of him
here.